[موسيقى]
الموسيقى الموسيقى هي لغه عالميه
لاحاسيسنا والمايسترو الذي نقدمه اليوم هو
من ابلغ متحدثيها عراب في صناعتها يعطيها
رؤيه جديده وبعدا اخر ياخذنا مع ارتفاع
يده الى اقصى مشاعرنا ومع انخفاضها الى
اعمق عواطفنا هو سفير الموسيقى السوريه
بكونه قائدا للفرقه السيمفونيه الوطنيه
وقائدا اساسيا
كما انه يراس القسم الموسيقي لمشروع بكره
لنا الذي تنظمه محافظه دمشق نحن
الاوركسترا هو عنوان خطابنا القادم
وضابط الايقاع هو متحدثنا الرابع
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير
وانا كتير سعيد بوجودي معكم اليوم
خاصه انه رح نحكي عن موضوع دايما بيشغل
بالي بحس انه نحن لازم
نتشارك مع بعض بهالفقار هاي
وكنا عم نحكي بموضوع مع فريق التنظيم فكرت
اللي ممكن نحكي عنه خاصه علاقه الاوركسترا
وعلاقتي مع الاوركسترا وكيف بشوف انا
موضوع الاوركسترا بالنسبه للمجتمع فمن هون
طلعت فكره نحن
قبل ما نبلش خلينا نشوف شو هي الاوركسترا
نحن بنعرف الاوركسترا هي مجموعه من
الوثيين ماسكين الاتون وعم بيعزفوا
بهالمسرح ولكن بالحقيقه كلمه اوركسترا اجت
من
وقت اليونان فبالمسرح الاغريقي المساحه
الموجوده بين الجمهور وبين المسرح هي كانت
اسمها
كان ممكن يكون فيها موسيقيين او مغنيين
راقصين فاي شخص موجود بهذا المكان كان
بيحمل اسم اوكيسرا من اسم المكان
مع بعض مجموعه من الاشخاص
اشخاص مختلفين بين بعضهم يا ترى ممكن
يكونوا اوركسترا للاشخاص
لنشوف تعالوا نعطيهم الات موسيقيه نسلم
هم
ولكن صار في تقليد بالاوركستا لحتى ما
يصير هذا التشتيت اللوني اللي شايفينه
نحنا ونشوف اختلافات الاشخاص انه اعضاء
الاوركسترا اعضاء الفرق الموسيقيه يلبسوا
لون حيادي الاسود والابيض فبيبقى الاختلاف
الوحيد الموجود اللي بنشوفه هم الالات
الموسيقيه
اختلاف في الالات الموسيقيه لانه حقيقه
اذا بنشوف الاوركسترا هي قاعده بنشوف
الالوان هدول فراح اشوف انه في عنا الالات
الاحمر الالات الوتريات
الاصفر الات النفخ الخشبيه الاخضر هنن
الاتفخ النحاسيه
والمواد مختلف اداه الايقاع ففعليا نحن في
عنا
اختلاف بالالات بالنوعيه الصوتيه اللي
بتصدر من الالات هاي ولكن كل الالات هاي
عم تعزف بانسجام او عم نسمع موسيقى منسجمه
نتيجه للمؤلف كيف كتبها والكوندكتور كيف
عم يشتغل والموسين كيف عم بيقدوا اذا
بندخل بتفاصيل اكثر جوات الاوركيس رح نشوف
انه هالالوان تحولت لاشكال ففي عنا الالات
المختلفه بين بعضها البعض وفي مكان اللي
هو مكاني هو هذا المكان تبع
شو بيعمل لحتى بتعمل الانسجام او يطلع
الصوت من الاوركسترا
انا بكون واقف للاسف ظهري للجمهور فما
بشوفكم بالحفلات ويكون الاوركسترا قاعدين
بمجموعاتهم كلها
وبتلاقوا الكوندكتر عم بيحرك ايديك يا ترى
في شي معين عم بيكون للكوندكتور هو عم
بيحرك ايديه تعالوا نشوف
شايفين
هدول نكت عن قائد شو بيعمل ولكن حقيقه قال
الاوركسترا بيكون عنده مدونه موسيقيه فيها
كتير اسطر شايفين الالوان اللي شفناهم قبل
شوي الاحمر والاصفر والاخضر هدول
المجموعات الاليه موجودين على المدونه
اللي عنده قاعده
بالنسبه للكوندكتور هاد الجزء هو كله سطر
واحد وهذا سطر واحد فالعازف بشوف خط من
الخطوط هذول بينما الكوندكتور هو عم يشوف
كل الخطوط مع بعض فهو عندهم مخطط الكامل
لهندسه العمل الموسيقي
بتقنيات تم اعتمادها وحركات تم اعتمادها
يفهم الموسيقيين رؤيته الموسيقيه اخراج
الموسيقى للعمل طبعا هذا بياخد وقت
بالتدريبات اثناء التدريبات قلت لكم عم
بيكون عم يدخل بالتفاصيل وعم يشتغلوا مع
بعض لحتى يطلعوا صوت منسجم طبعا هذا نفسه
موجود بالمجتمع لانه المجتمع كمان نحن
مختلفين بين بعضنا البعض وفي ايقاع عم
بيبط عم بيربط حلاقتنا علاقتنا مع بعض
البعض وبنفس الوقت في منظومه نحن عايشين
ضمننا هي اللي بتضبط وجودنا الاجتماعي
وبخلوا الانسجام دواء جوات المجتمع تماما
مثل ما
هيدا نقول انه الاوركسترا هو تمثيل
للمجتمع مثل ما المجتمع هو كمان
يعني الموسيقى اللي بتشوفوه لابس طقم هو
الصبح عم بفيق عم بيعاني نفس المشاكل
بيعاني في اي شخص موجود بهذا المجتمع
عنده ازماته ولكن
مهنته صارت هي الموسيقى فبالتالي هو
وظيفته انه يطلع على المسرح لحتى يؤدي شيء
موسيقى تقدر تساعد المجتمع انه يتجاوز
كتير من الازمات انه يتجاوز حالاته
النفسيه يعني جمهور بيجي على المسرح لحتى
يغير حالته النفسيه ليكون جلسه من الطب
النفسي او العلاج النفسي بينفل الجمهور
طبعا نتيجه كل هاد الاخير في عنا الحفل
الموسيقي بالحفل الموسيقي بتطلع النتيجه
الجمهور بيحضر
نتاج العمل الاوركسترالي بين القائد
الاوركسترا والموسيقيين وبنهايه طبعا بدنا
اكيد لازم نسمع موسيقى فرح نسمع عمل اسمه
هي العجوز اللي بسته جنيه سته كانون
الثاني ايطاليا بتجي وبتوزع للاطفال يلي
كانوا شاطرين اثناء السنه الماضيه هدايا
او
سكاكر وشغلات طيبه والاطفال اللي ما كانوا
شاطرين بتوزع لهم فحمات فهي بتيجي على
المكنسه تبعها مثل الساحره اللي نحن كنا
نشوفها وهو طقس كثير مهم بالنسبه للاطفال
بايطاليا حتى انه المؤلف اوتورينو رسميكي
الف عمل اسمه فيستي روماني الاعياد
البيروما وسكر هي الشخصيه بعمل موسيقيه
اللي رح نسمعها مع الفرقه السيمفونيه
الوطنيه السوريه
شكرا كثير لكم واتمنى لكم استمتاع مع
الموسيقى شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]